well what the results are telling us so
far are that joe biden has the easiest
path to power you can see he's currently
on 253
electoral college votes but despite
three days of counting you cannot rule
out donald trump yet
he's on 214. i just want to take you to
three
swing states that i've got my eye on
because things aren't narrowing and they
could be
decisive georgia first georgia hasn't
been democrats since bill clinton won it
all the way back in at 1992. it's
currently too close to call and it
really is
just look at how close it is with 96
of the vote in there's only 0.4 in it
donald trump
just in front but joe biden's catching
up because a lot of those
key counties around atlanta are still
bringing their vote in so really really
close in uh georgia
in arizona it's also too close to call
joe biden's actually in the lead right
now
in arizona but it's tightening in the
other direction donald trump's starting
to catch up
so really really close in arizona too
so no republican has actually taken the
white house without
arizona so that's really one to watch
out for and
finally pennsylvania the birthplace of
joe biden he's currently
uh trailing donald trump you might think
that that is a bit of more of a sizable
gap but only 89
of the votes are in pennsylvania and
actually if the trends continue
joe biden could very well end up taking
at this state from
donald trump so what you're seeing is
this is the explanation perhaps why
you're saying donald trump supporters
chanting stop
the votes stop the counting the votes in
pennsylvania and count the votes in
arizona because things are really mixed
we're also expecting to hear
a news conference from donald trump a
little bit later on he's decided to give
it from nevada
the city that apparently never sleeps of
course but they have actually did go to
bed so that's why we're still waiting
for some of those baits to come in only
86 in uh joe biden uh in the lead there
but it's too close to call
now i'll be interested to hear what
donald trump has to say because although
as i said
it does look like joe brad has got the
easier path to power donald trump
has really confounded expectations so
far
and just to show you how i've got this a
graphic that charts
how people expected donald trump to do
in the polls with how he did in reality
and you can see the bright red line here
is uh the pole result for donald trump
the darker line is the reality
and he's outperformed expectation in
texas
in ohio in minnesota it's the same story
it's also the same story
in iowa and of course very memorably
florida what does that tell us tell us
that the pollsters have again
been underestimating donald trump's
support and that is why things are much
much closer
than we thought they might be well let's
have a quick check now
on the race so far the race to the
winning line of 270
electoral college votes and this
is a situation that you can see things
really really close as we
finally start to approach the white
house
there you can see joe biden on 253
electoral votes donald trump on 214
we're waiting for georgia that's
probably going to be next and that could
be a sizable
amount to give to one of those two men